during the latter half of the 1990s one
of hollywood's biggest emerging stars
was none other than brendan fraser the
american canadian actor originally
gained widespread appeal through
comedies like encino man and george of
the jungle his biggest hit however came
in the form of a soft remake of a
classic 1932 horror film 1999's the
mummy starring frasier as american
adventurer rick o'connell the mummy went
on to gross over 155 million dollars
worldwide sparking a franchise that
would spawn two sequels a spin-off film
series and an animated show over the
next 10 years both sequels the mummy
returns and the mummy tomb of the dragon
emperor managed to rake in far more than
their predecessors despite this string
of great successes as a leading man
frasier would soon fade from the public
eye he worked consistently for a few
years after tomb of the dragon emperor
was released though not in anything with
the same widespread appeal as the mummy
franchise and then he seemed to
disappear entirely between 2015 and 2017
frasier seemingly swore off film
altogether and only appeared in a
handful of smaller scale tv roles as it
turns out a major factor in fraser's
disappearance from show business during
this time had to do with the mummy tomb
of the dragon emperor and its
predecessors in the mummy series he
later revealed that the franchise ended
up doing some serious damage to his
acting career literally in an interview
with gq in 2018 frasier candidly
revealed one of the things that caused
his hollywood hiatus essentially he was
at the end of his rope from over
exertion and injuries by the time i did
the third mummy picture in china i was
put together with tape and ice screw cap
ice packs and downhill mountain biking
pads cause they're small and light and
they can fit under your clothes i was
building an exoskeleton for myself daily
frazier was often his own stunt man and
injuries were not uncommon for the actor
he eventually needed to have surgery and
sometimes even those didn't go as
planned as frasier recalled i needed a
laminectomy and the lumbar didn't take
so they had to do it again a year later
while it might not have been the mummy
tomb of the dragon emperor that directly
caused all of these injuries it was the
film that amplified them and caused
frasier to slow down frazier also had a
partial knee replacement and lots of
painful work done on his back
additionally the actor needed to have
his vocal cords worked on frazier
remembered being in and out of hospitals
for just under seven years he was broken
and exhausted and enough was enough
in a sad comparison frazier compared
himself to a george orwell character i
felt like the horse from animal farm
whose job it was to work and work and
work orwell wrote a character who was i
think the proletariat he worked for the
good of the whole he didn't ask
questions he didn't make trouble until
it killed him
thankfully fraser has opted to slow down
a bit following this era of rest and
recovery his biggest breadwinner at the
moment doom patrol involves considerably
less physical risk for the 52 year old
even so he manages to bring much of the
personality that helped make him such an
effective leading man big things
continue to happen for the beloved actor
as he's recently been cast in martin
scorsese's killers of the flower moon
frazier will star alongside robert de
niro and leonardo dicaprio two actors he
hasn't had the pleasure of working with
yet additionally he is slated to appear
in brothers which is an upcoming comedy
film from legendary pictures after
showing fans that he's still got it in
steven soderbergh's recent flick no
sudden move supporters of frasier are
more than ecstatic to see him back in
the limelight we couldn't be more
excited for him check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite actors
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]